nous avons hospitalisé 337 personnes une
soixantaine d'interventions
chirurgicales le deuxième mois 450 le
troisième mois est en train de se
dérouler et les chiffres augmentent sans
cesse
bien sûr nous ne sommes pas contentés de
cette besogne de médecine curative et
nous avons été chargés aussi de
l'hygiène du camp en liaison avec le
comité des vietnamiens sur l'île il faut
s'arranger pour que les vietnamiens qui
viendront ici toucheront d'ailleurs en
quantité relativement mince par rapport
aux chômeurs qui par conséquent ne
prendront pas beaucoup de travail aux
chômeurs mais il faut s'arranger pour
que les en est est ce que vous
considérez que le gouvernement français
a fait quelque chose face aux problèmes
de réfugiés selon moi oui il a fait
quelque chose j'avais fait beaucoup
cinquante mille réfugiés c'est pas mal
mais il n'a pas fait ce qu'il faut faire
c'est à dire la situation s'étant
aggravée depuis qu'il a pris ses
décisions il faut maintenant qu'ils
rouvrent les possibilités d'entrée ans
jean paul sartre que s'il ya des
réfugiés va certainement y avoir des
causes des raisons ne pensais pas qu'il
serait peut-être bon et judicieux
d'aller voir véritablement au viêt-nam
pourquoi tous ces gens veulent me
quitter
parce qu'il n'aime pas le régime
communiste qui d'ailleurs rétablit
lentement et difficilement étant donné
les ravages pour poser sur la terre
vietnamienne la situation en vue vietnam
est encore très difficile
et comme le système communiste ne plaît
pas à tout le monde
il est évident que ces gens qui ont pu
d'ailleurs
combattre pour projet nam nouveau est
lâché oui un certain temps
dans ces conditions
l'opinion de ses jambes sheikh le
vietnam ne nous importent pas
il n'aime pas de régime c'est tellement
qui est établie mais ça ne regarde ça
regarde e et des populations l'état
mienne ce qu'il ya c'est que sont des
hommes en danger mortel et ce sont ces
hommes qu'il faut secourir parce que ce
sont des angles